Hola bienvenidos una nueva emisión de la
entrevista en Franz 24 en español es
junio y comienza el mes del orgullo
lgbtiq más una época de celebración de
la visibilidad de la diversidad las
conquistas y también por supuesto de
continuidad de la lucha y los reclamos
por las deudas y derechos pendientes
para la población
lgbtiq más pero también un mes en el que
aparece con mucha fuerza un movimiento
que se apropia de las consignas y de los
símbolos y también de las narrativas del
colectivo y amenaza con quitarle Su
contenido y también su fuerza capaz de
generar cambios hablamos sobre el pin
washing y para esto nos acompaña milagro
mariona periodista activista lesbiana y
feminista ella edita y dirige el diario
La nota en tucumán Argentina milagro
Mariana Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista
Hola Santiago Muchas gracias a vos y
bueno por el espacio y poder estar acá
gracias a vos nuevamente Comencemos por
la pregunta básica y principal Qué es el
pin washing
es una una forma que tenemos de a esto
que hacen las empresas en el mes del
orgullo que es apropiarse de de este
valor que tiene que ver con la
reivindicación de derechos para
utilizarlo para vender en sus marcas no
vemos que aparece los colores del
orgullo en las vidrieras en las
publicidades
incluso también muchos gobiernos no
solamente hablemos de empresas sino
también la algunos gobiernos en donde
tal vez digamos las poblaciones no gozan
de sus derechos Pero bueno tienen este
esta este utilización de los símbolos
para mostrar también una mirada progre
no
Pink washing significa
lavado Rosa también esto lo vemos que
sucede con el movimiento feminista con
fechas como el ocho de marzo incluso con
el tres de junio acá en Argentina en
donde bueno se trata de fechas que
tienen un peso simbólico muy fuerte que
tienen que ver con la reivindicación de
derechos y que están marcados por hechos
trágicos no en este caso el mes del
orgullo por la lucha en estongol no se
trata de una cuestión mercantilista si
no se trata de una cuestión de
reivindicación de derechos ahora una
pregunta clave no Qué tipo de orgullos y
de identidades construye el mercado a
quienes les habla el mercado durante el
mes del orgullo
bueno justamente no le habla a una
población que tiene sus derechos
vulnerables y no le habla a una
población que probablemente pueda
acceder a ese tipo de de objetos que
venden no
se trata también de una
individualización de las personas no la
lucha del colectivo lgbt siempre se se
caracterizó por ser en comunidad por ser
con las otras personas por eso hablamos
de los colectivos lgbt en cambio estas
estas campañas vienen a mostrarnos a
personas individuales a personas de
politizadas personas en donde no se ve
este contenido político que le ponemos
siempre a las luchas por el orgullo
Entonces le habla a una frase social
también que tiene acceso a otros
recursos económicos le habla también
probablemente a personas hegemónicas
blancas delgadas no en donde no vemos
Esta diversidad la cual justamente
hablamos cuando hablamos de orgullo no
ahora hablemos de una frase que está muy
presente que ya es una suerte de eslogan
está muy presente también en las
publicidades en este mes de hecho se usa
mucho Incluso en inglés no Love Is Love
en español El amor es amor Bueno esto
tiene varios puntos para analizar pero
recientemente voy a citar una película
que recientemente que se titula Bros y
planteaba algo muy interesante no el
protagonista un varón homosexual dice
que esa frase es una mentira creada para
ser tratados con justicia como iguales y
él plantea no que el amor heterosexual
no es para nada igual al amor homosexual
que sus relaciones son diferentes
incluso su vida sexual es diferente hay
en esa frase crees algún reduccionismo
de la diversidad al amor entre dos
personas que borra digamos las
particularidades de cada individuo
y claramente tiene ese ese efecto no a
la subjetividad de las personas por un
lado también demostrarnos con estas
campañas inclusivas de que ya se llegó a
cierto piso de derechos y a cierto nivel
en donde ya somos todos iguales y la
verdad que no somos todas las personas
iguales Incluso en Argentina que es un
país que es vanguardia en la conquista
de derechos sabemos que incluso hoy
siguen habiendo actos de violencia actos
de discriminación y en cuanto a esta
esta frase La que incluso digamos en
inglés no nos representa en lo absoluto
sabemos y siempre lo hemos marcado que
no se trata del mismo amor es otro amor
que está marcado por la discriminación
que está marcado por la superación de
esa discriminación Me parece que el
movimiento
lgbt ha sabido traer no todos estos
colores estos brillos a la lucha y y a
festejar las conquistas pero sin dejar
de reconocer que lo que hay atrás de
esas conquistas es muchísima lucha Y
también muchísimas muertes muchísimas
muertes violentas de personas
representantes del colectivo o personas
que no tienen nada que ver con la lucha
política pero que han sido asesinadas
discriminadas vulneradas incluso
constantemente excluidas de todo los
derechos del Salud Educación entonces No
podemos pensar que se construye de la
misma manera el amor del colectivo lgbt
de en todas sus diversidades del amor
existe heterosexual cuando hablamos de
la heterosexualidad no estamos hablando
solamente de dos personas que de
distintos sexo que se aman estamos
hablando de un sistema no de un sistema
normativo que establece jerarquías en la
sociedad entonces esa reduccionismo es
un reduccionismo que bueno justamente
viene a querer decirnos Bueno ya está
todo conquistado ya está ahora dejen de
luchar por sus derechos y bueno sabemos
que no es así que queda un largo camino
todavía por delante absolutamente ahora
milagro hay ciertas personas no de
identidad diversa que utilizan esta
frase verdad sobre todo a lo largo de
este mes de junio ahí crees cierta
permeabilidad en el colectivo lgbt al
Pink washing
y bueno claramente sí claramente tenemos
digamos hay hay sectores que que
prefieren y se sienten cómodos y cómodas
Y cómodes con esa frase y con llegar a
cierto estatus quo y poder acceder a
ciertos derechos y gozar de esta
visibilidad porque bueno esas personas
probablemente tienen ya garantizado
ciertos derechos Pero bueno sabemos que
desde el colectivo y desde quienes
venimos impulsando justamente que hay
que seguir politizando sabemos que Que
bueno que las desigualdades que nos
atraviesan son para todo el colectivo y
que tenemos que luchar colectivamente
para salir de ahí para mí hay una frase
que a mí me gusta mucho que que dice no
nos une el amor nos une El espanto será
por eso que te quiero tanto y justamente
digamos creo que en las luchas del
colectivo lgbt lo que nos unió
siempre fue la discriminación
fue la exclusión la marginación Y desde
ese lugar encontramos la fortaleza para
unirnos y para luchar y ahí surge el
amor No pero no es el amor entre dos
personas en el amor en lo colectivo el
amor a una vida libre de violencia Me
parece que que esa reivindicación es la
que tenemos que seguir dando y lejos
digamos de esta idea también más
individualista neoliberal
consumista y capitalista creo que
también en un contexto donde si bien
hemos conquistado un montón de derechos
tenemos un una avanzada de discursos más
conservadores y de derecha que vienen
por nuestros derechos lo escuchamos en
los discursos de candidatos y candidatas
a las presidenciales acá en Argentina y
que la verdad digamos tenemos que estar
muy atentos porque vienen a atentar
contra todos nuestros derechos
ahora se crea crees también una Falsa
ilusión de apertura y de libertades que
terminan cuando termina el mes de junio
Bueno sí claramente digamos Estas ideas
se se repiten ahora en junio y acá en
Argentina que tenemos la la marcha el
orgullo suele ser en noviembre y
diciembre tenemos ahí un ratito más de
de estos discursos en donde claramente
es circunstancial es una apropiación
pero que después la vida concreta y real
de las personas sigue siendo la misma
antes durante y después de junio no
salvo que esto se Luche y se ejerza en
nuestro derecho a poder seguir exigiendo
mejores condiciones de vida acá en
Argentina por ejemplo lo que es la ley
de cupo laboral Trump para estas
empresas que que utilizan los colores de
la diversidad y queda mucho más
efectivo si realmente les interesa la
diversidad realmente les interesan
nuestros derechos que tomen y contraten
a personas del colectivo lgbt por
ejemplo personas que realmente
ahora también se apropian de consignas
de narrativas y de imágenes en el ámbito
político verdad milagro hay un ejemplo
muy patente en Argentina vamos a hablar
de Horacio Rodríguez larreta jefe de
gobierno de la ciudad de Buenos Aires de
ideología de derecha no él prohibió el
lenguaje inclusivo en los Colegios de la
ciudad pero por ejemplo tiñó el obelisco
no el icónico obelisco de Buenos Aires
con los colores de la bandera lgbt
debemos entonces prestar atención
también al sector público pero no dejar
de lado el privado verdad
por supuesto por supuesto
es un claro ejemplo este que vos das
también hay una estación de subte que
lleva el nombre de jauretche que fue uno
de los referentes de la lucha en
Argentina por los derechos lgbt Entonces
se apropian de nuestros símbolos yo creo
que siempre hemos estado ahí para
señalarlo justamente creo que el
colectivo lgbt en Argentina el colectivo
también travesti trans que es referente
en Latinoamérica de la lucha siempre
hemos estado a la vanguardia digo como
los derechos que hemos conquistado los
derechos que hay en Argentina es
justamente porque hay una militancia
activa que no deja pasar estas cosas no
creo que que bueno como pasa en la
mayoría de los países también donde
estos progresismos también se cuelan un
poco en estos discursos de derecha hay
que estar muy atentos porque significa
no no representa un avance real sino
solamente una máscara para mostrar a la
sociedad que
se esté inclusivo y que hay política de
diversidad cuando en la realidad algo
tan simple y tan sencillo pero que cala
tan profundo como era el lenguaje
inclusivo se prohíbe en unas escuelas
digamos cómo es posible que eso vaya la
mano de los avances de derechos
milagro nos queda muy poco tiempo menos
de un minuto pero no quiero dejar de
realizarte la siguiente pregunta no en
este contexto de contradicciones de
luchas por la apropiación de consignas y
lavadas de imagen como venimos hablando
Cómo podemos todos celebrar el orgullo
manteniendo fuerte el grito emancipador
contra todo tipo de violencia y de
discriminación
poder recuperar la historia de nuestras
luchas no solamente de que está muy
presente sino también las propias luchas
de Argentina y de cada territorio porque
reconociendo nuestra historia y teniendo
memoria es que podemos construir un
presente más
y también un futuro para las próximas
generaciones creo que es lo que se está
viendo en Argentina que vemos a infancia
y que vemos a infancias
con diferentes identidades de género
identidades orientaciones sexuales que
hoy pueden ser libres entonces me parece
que vamos por el camino correcto y que
tenemos que seguir fortaleciendo
nuestros discursos milagro Mariana
Muchísimas gracias por tu presencia en
la entrevista de France 24
gracias a ustedes gracias a ti una vez
más a nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a seguir informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
France 24.com sigan junto a nosotros